l'une des nombreuses choses dont un virus ou une
bactérie a besoin pour prospérer est un
système circulatoire fonctionnant avec un hôte vivant
j'ai bien peur que cela se résume à un simple
fait ne pas rendre malade une personne morte un
zombie est un organisme qui est contrôlé
et n'a pas de fin  point sur lui-même, il est
mort dans le cas du système biologique,
ils sont morts pour la reproduction, je pense
qu'ils propagent l'agent pathogène et ils ont
besoin d'un hôte sain dans le film, nous voyons
un comportement dirigé vers un objectif lorsque les
zombies mordent un individu cet
individu lui-même  essaie de rechercher et de
trouver plus d'hôtes c'est exactement ce que nous
voyons dans le monde naturel, nous pouvons voir des
parasites lorsqu'ils infectent un autre
individu cet individu lui-même
essaie de transmettre des copies des gènes du parasite
à un biologiste intéressé par les maladies
tout ce genre de zombies  est
absolument fascinant parce qu'il
nous décrit la préoccupation générale de la
société vis-à-vis des maladies qui viennent d'
ailleurs,
le film comme celui-ci est une façon de
faire comprendre que quelque chose  ing new
peut surgir de nulle part et se propager
très rapidement
et dans cette mesure, même un film sur des
zombies
essayant de conquérir le monde est en
fait exact
vous